in the last video we were able to
calculate the real return by putting
everything in today's dollars put that
hundred dollars we invested a year going
today's dollars figure out what our
actual return was our dollar return is
in today's dollars and then we got our
real return what I want to think about
in this video is how we can do it
another way we can actually put
everything in last year's money so we
got one hundred and ten dollars let's
put one hundred ten dollars
let's put one hundred ten of today's
money $100 ten of today's money in in
last year's money last years years money
and to think about this we could we
could do a little algebra or you don't
have to do algebra but maybe that makes
a little bit more intuitive there's some
amount of money last year there's some
amount of money let's call that X that
if we multiply it by the inflation rate
so if we grow it by two percent so if we
grow it by two percent that's going to
be worth one hundred and ten dollars
today that's going to be worth 110 110
dollars today or to just solve for X you
divide both sides by 1.02 and we get the
amount of money that if you grow it by
inflation or that had the same amount of
purchasing power as $110 today would be
110 divided by 1.0 - which is let me
scroll over to the right a little bit
this would be 110 110 divided by one
point zero two so this would be equal to
one hundred and seven point eight
dollars just roughly just to round it so
this is equal to one hundred seven point
eight dollars so 110 110 dollars today
buys us the exact same thing if you
believe the whole CPI index as one
hundred and seven dollars and eighty
cents and maybe I could even add another
digit 84 cents and 84 cents would have
bought us last year so what is our
dollar return in last year's money
dollar return in last year's in last
year's money last year's money well we
ended up with 107 point eight four
dollars and last year's money so 107
point eight for 100
seven dollars and 84 cents and we had
originally invested in last year's money
$100 we had originally invested $100
so our dollar return is seven dollars
and 84 cents or if you want to calculate
the real return the real return how much
did our actual purchasing power increase
well we got a 7.8 e four dollar return
off of a hundred dollar investment and
so this is pretty easy to calculate we
once again get to the same seven point
eight percent for the real return